so i'm gonna oh it's starting to record
now so
um yeah right so we'll start the meeting
and um if it is being recorded now i'm
i'm sorry that we are actually late uh i
think
all the members and officers realize
that there's been some technical
problems but um i'm i'm david atten and
i'm chair of this committee
um and i'd like to welcome all members
and officers to this meeting of pandemic
exclusional committee
please remember to mute your mic
when when you're not speaking and use
the
raise hand feature when you wish to
speak
um we have two main items on the agenda
tonight what one is public health than
adult ken
and i think there are three sort of
parts to that and
reports have been sent to all members
and the other is the ofsted update
and again members have received a report
on those items um
so if we if we go on to the agenda
itself
uh attendances um we
we have three of colleges councillors
new
shaw and blackburn um
and i know that the executive member for
health and well-being and equality
will join the meeting later
she has work commitments and we'll be
here at five so
in that respect i intend to change the
agenda
slightly to accommodate the executive
member jane
slater so items six
and seven will be will change
places i hope that's uh agreeable to
everybody okay with that
um item three is declarations of
interest if you've got any interest in
any of the items please can you
let us know now
are there any no okay
item four questions from the public uh
i've not received any
uh item five is urgent business and
again i've not received any urgent
business
so we do go now on to our main items
which
um as i said before we're going to
rearrange the agenda so
it's item 7 that we're looking at and
we'll go back to 6
when we finished item seven this is the
hofstede
update and uh this item
uh we have in attendance councillor
heinz who is the executive member
for children's services and jill
mcgregor
corporate director for children's
services
and i'll pass over to
councillor heinz and
and jill mcgregor thanks
very much chair um so we wanted to bring
um this report to pandemic scrutiny
um tonight because um as part of the
um the the usual arrangements
um we were providing regular reports
actually to
the children's scrutiny committee on the
progress
of ofsted and we felt that it was
incredibly important really that we did
provide
people with an update and give members
an opportunity to ask us
some questions and and i will in a
couple of minutes just hand over
um to jill to to talk you through all of
that um
but i guess i did want to really
recognize that since the last time we
provided um an update um there has been
an incredible
amount of of work on um on our
improvement journey um and i think
what you'll find um is that that there
has been a lot of progress
um and that um is in no small part
due to um the immense commitment
of our all of our staff really
and from the council as a whole i think
who have tried
very much to wrap around support for
children's services and but what you'll
also find i think is that there is still
a lot to to do um on
that journey um and you know there is a
lot of work that is
is ongoing um which jill jill will touch
on
um in a few moments um
but i think we do have to recognize as
well that
we have been through or are still going
through
um some incredibly
significant challenges which i think
everybody will
recognize um with with covid
and what that has meant um it has
presented
um as people would expect some
challenges
in terms of our improvement journey and
we've very much
um tried to align our improvement
journey
with um the priorities that we've had to
set really for
um dealing with the pandemic and i think
we've talked to this committee in
in the past really about um lots of
those challenges really
um and how children's social care um
in general has been impacted by the
pandemic how
we've had some really big significant
worries about um some of our vulnerable
families and how we keep in touch with
them
and we have absolutely um
made all attempts really to to ensure
that we can
keep in touch with our vulnerable
families and and
children um but obviously things are are
very different in the world
um that we're in so there has been an
impact on that improvement journey
um but that is not to say that we are
not um
you know as committed as as all as we
have always been
um to making the improvements that are
required
um and with that i will hand over
to jill thank you thank you
thank you for that introduction
councillor hines
and apologies for it being a lengthy
report and in addition we provided a set
of slides
it felt really important though to give
a degree of detail because as
councillor heinz has
articulated and indicated it has been a
while since we've formally
presented at scrutiny and obviously the
arrangements that we're working in
at the moment mean that it's a different
set of scrutiny arrangements
so with that in mind i did take the
liberty to remind
um committee members of some of the
findings and some of the issues that
were identified
in what feels an incredibly long time
ago
really and from a chronological point of
view it is quite a while ago
but obviously there have been a number
of events not least the circumstances
that we're working
in that have impacted on that i think
it's fair to say that broadly speaking
the findings were about the leadership
and the management of the service
and what those leaders and managers
actually understood about the quality of
practice on front
on the front line and what they were
doing to support that
and so a number of things that we have
needed to do
have had to get to the heart of that
so we have needed to strengthen our
management arrangements and that's not
just through the provision of
posts but actually really thinking about
what our role is what we need to do and
how we are helpful to our practitioners
because nobody comes to work to do a bad
job
and i think one of the things that was
so challenging for the inspection
and the findings was that recognition
that
ultimately um it meant we weren't
getting things
right consistently for our children and
our families in the borough and that was
something that
i think the service on the council felt
very keenly
um and we've needed to acknowledge that
in order to move forward
as part of that obviously there was a
commitment to
have permanent leadership arrangements
in place through the recruitment of
myself as a dcs
but equally to think about what we
needed to support at
team team level so that every team
had a dedicated team leader that they
had manageable caseloads and that they
could be supported in
all that they were doing and they were
things that
we saw some significant success in to
begin with
i think it's fair to say that um as we
went into the pandemic we had ambitious
plans
we had ambitious plans for how we could
take the work forward
building on the success that had already
happened
and to really have that rapid
acceleration
so we identified that we needed to
further strengthen our leadership
arrangements we identified that
we needed to make sure that managers at
every level
understood what good practice looked
like what
uh what that meant for our children and
families lived experiences
and we absolutely recognized that we
needed to move on from having plans that
were about
scaffolding structural arrangements to
actually that real focus
on practice
and our ambitious plans that we wanted
to take
forward we had hoped to do that through
a series of
um workshops that could be really really
inclusive
because recognizing that safeguarding is
a shared responsibility recognizing that
we're all committed to our children and
families we wanted to do that
on that basis unfortunately
as soon as we made those plans we did go
into lockdown
we were also due to have our monitoring
visit from ofsted at that point
and that would have been ofsted coming
in and formally assessing our progress
up until that point as we went into
lockdown
ofsted weren't able to come to us but
they did
they had completed the prep work as had
we so they offered us
the opportunity or we asked for rather
than they offered us the opportunity
just to assess where they thought we
were at
and they did absolutely acknowledge that
there had been significant progress made
at that point
they acknowledged that the governance
and and our actual
quality assurance systems had been
strengthened
um they absolutely recognized
the strength and the leadership that had
been shown corporately and by the
council
and they have continued to be impressed
by that in terms of saying that there
has been that wrap around children's
services
one of the key areas that they
acknowledged that had significantly
improved was the front door
so our initial response when concerns
are first identified
when issues are first raised
that we had invested significantly in
staff
that we had much better oversight and
that we did
actually have an appropriate response
they also recognized
that the work we were asking our
practitioners to do our
social work is to do
was now much more balanced in that they
had reasonable caseloads and that was
something that the council
absolutely committed to and
whilst that's broadly still the case
there are some pressures because of
surges through the pandemic
what they also identified though was
that probably one of the things that we
needed to think about was how we could
accelerate
and really expand our improvement
and i think just that point that
councillor hines has made
about actually when we're in a lockdown
situation
when all of our services are needing to
think about
different ways of working that
inevitably is going to have an impact
on the extent to which you can be
innovative further expand and further it
improve
having said that we have taken a very
clear approach to our improvement
activity
and what we have said is if you're doing
the right thing
for our children and families ofsted and
improvement takes care of itself
because actually by doing the right
things you will be improving
services in reality what that means is
we have stripped things back to basics
so even when we have been in full
lockdown and as we move into tier three
we said the primary thing that we need
to do
is to be helpful to our children and
families
is to visit our children and families to
talk to them about what's happening
to focus on how we can help we've also
sustained
our multi-agency processes so we've
still continued to have
our child protection conferences our
meetings with other professionals
and to take forward plans for our our
children and families we've also done
a lot of work with our partners to
actually refresh our improvement plan
and at the last improvement board we
have that plan signed off
and that plan really talks about what we
are already doing
and what we will continue to do
to strengthen our service offer and
actually how we will do that in
partnership
and whilst that sounds a simple thing to
do
it's absolutely right that we say what
is it that we are going to do that will
make a difference to our children and
families
more recently as well as strengthening
um
thinking about the leadership team we
have now recruited a new director for
early help and children social care
kathy rooney retired last month having
given
years of dedicated service to trafford
we've also created a strategic lead role
for practice improvement and learning
recognizing that improvement and
learning is a continuous process
and their specific role will be to
support
our staff at every level to learn and
celebrate when things go right
but to absolutely implement a model of
coaching and support for our frontline
practitioners
i've touched on the fact that we've
already co-designed and refreshed our
improvement plan and one of the key
aspects within that
is how we make sure that our help is
responsive
and that it happens at the earliest
possible stage
early when problems start to arise but
early in children's lives
and so we're really moving at pace in
terms of
our redesigned locality
early help offer
we've also challenged ourselves in terms
of
having made a number of changes having
put scaffolding place
do we really understand what our
frontline practice looks like
is our quality assurance framework
making a difference
and actually are we taking the learning
forward from that
and to support with that we did
commission an independent consultant
to do some targeted and very detailed
pieces of work with our managers
and to check out what practical skills
they had in terms of those qa processes
and we're now implementing a detailed
plan of support around each manager at
every level
we have also had our our dfe
progress review and i think it's fair to
say the findings
of that were quite pleasing whilst
recognizing that there was more to do
but critically we recognize that we
still need to strengthen some of our
practice
and like i say we're trying to break
that up as well as being ambitious for
our children and families
and so at this moment in time the way
that we have
broken it up is to say in order to be
supporting our families we need to see
them
we need to see our children we need to
talk to them we need to understand what
life is like
for them we need to share our
information
we need to use our multi-agency meetings
as the vehicle for driving forward plans
we have continued to make sure that
we've got oversight
of every contact and every referral at
the front door so that continues to be
a strength we have recognized
that working in the pandemic is
different for our practitioners
and we have issued specific guidance on
how to look after our staff
at such times um recognizing that
it's a challenging time for them as well
as our families
so some of the the soft touch things you
know like how to keep in touch
how to support your staff we
absolutely have maintained our
multi-agency processes
strategy meetings child protection
conferences
and core groups we've also
focused on what that means for our
children in care
recognizing that actually
being in this situation that we're in
could have
an adverse impact on placement stability
but actually
our placements are the places where our
children in care live
they're their homes and needing to wrap
around our foster carers our residential
staff
and our children to try and make sure
that we have the strength
that's needed in terms of that support
for our placements
we still have some more to do we have
had some instability in staffing
and we've done a detailed piece of work
in terms of what that looks like
and that's identifying a number of
issues
and one of those issues is that it's
really really important that we get the
support right to our practitioners
we still need to make sure that we
further embed our quality assurance
systems
so that we understand exactly what's
going well
what we need to further strengthen and
we have
implemented a different range of
performance clinics and auditing to help
with that
and that includes actually observing
people in practice
and seeing what they're doing when they
work with our families so as we can
understand how we might strengthen that
and equally celebrate what's going well
we have tried as i've said to phase and
stage our approach to improvement
recognizing that you can't do everything
all at once and that it's really
important that we make it feel
um make it feel doable for
our staff because if we just say you've
got to change everything
then probably things won't get done as
robustly or as well as you would want
we are really challenging ourselves and
thinking about
how we organize the service in a way
that is helpful
not just to our staff but to our
children and families
because we've got some groups of
services and some
managers that have spans of control
that they are interconnected but don't
necessarily go together in the same way
as you would want
so we've actually started down that pla
path of doing something
we have continued to meet with the
improvement board
and the improvement board has continued
to put challenge into the service
in terms of testing out whether the
things that i'm saying have got better
or are improving are improving and it's
really important that we're open to that
level of scrutiny and challenge
because we should not be in a position
whereby people are
are saying you don't know what's
happening
and i think at that point i'm probably
going to pause
there is a lot more detail in the report
but i just wanted to give a flavour and
an
overview and obviously i'm happy to
answer any questions
thanks for that quite detailed um
overview really i think i think it's
quite helpful
for you to go through it as you have
done
right i'll just open it up for questions
there any questions for members
oh i i have a few questions
um you would have been disappointed if
you didn't counselor acton
yeah um clearly
you know with improvement plans and you
you've
really touched on that and quality
assurance and so on
that you need very strong performance
management
of the targets that you're actually
setting and
i suppose it's how we
of the scrutiny committee can can
help in terms of that because
you know if we've got those clear
improvement targets um you know and
we've got
in place a performance management
role really um that that would
that would be helpful to uh to
to look at the progress that has been
made
um you know in a real way
obviously you know you you've set out a
number of
improvements that have been made but
it's how we actually
you know sort of scrutinize that
so just in terms of that and it's a
conversation that we've had at corporate
parenting as well isn't it counselor
acton
so in terms of the way that we have
approached the improvement plan and we
talk about
it in terms of our ambitions under every
one of those ambitions or some
performance indicators
the majority of which at the moment are
quantitative but we've also included
some qualitative measures
so for each of our eight ambitions we
have a series of key indicators
that should be the way that progress can
be
measured and challenged and
one of the things that i've put in in
the report is
that we would like um scrutiny to invite
us back
on an agreed frequency and that can
include
um formal reporting against those
performance indicators because i think
one of the things that
meant that we couldn't chart our
progress in quite the way that we would
want to
was because we hadn't tied our activity
to
and how will we know if we've got there
and what will the impact be
so we've deliberately approached our
refresh of the improvement
with clear indicators against each of
the different eight ambitions
so we would be more than happy to bring
some of that performance reporting back
um out of date in the future
that's really helpful jill um
i think the the other thing that i kind
of noted was the
independent consultant to talk to
to the staff and you know look at
strengths and weaknesses that we we may
have and how we can actually improve
those how is that actually going on the
ground
how did the staff feel about it as well
it was really interesting
and the staff talked about that work
even though it
wasn't anything that if you like our own
validation or
self-assessment had hadn't identified
the staff and the managers that were
directly part of that
coaching and challenge exercise
talked about it as being light bulb
moments and actually
um the approach of show and tell
show me where you think you've done that
this is what i'm seeing
and that support really did help people
think so they do talk about that work
by mary candelin they do talk about it
being challenging
but they also have her words echoing in
their ears so that
they're embracing that um we're
approaching things
in a different way that we are saying we
will coach we will support
so another example of that would be in
terms of changing
the performance clinic arrangements i've
had
individual sessions with all of the
strategic leads where i've given
feedback on
their performance reports that they've
said and said this is
good but it would be even better if
so i think from a changing culture point
of view
and absolutely recognizing
that we're all in this together and we
have to learn and we have to support our
staff to do it
i think they are feeling more confident
about the approach fair to say that some
people
think that me wanting to have a level of
detail sometimes
is quite forensic i make no apologies
for that because i think it's too
important it is our children and our
families lives that we're talking about
and it was one of the things that we
didn't get right
so i think it's really important that we
carry on with that
so broadly speaking most of them are
welcoming it they've embraced the
learning
we're also maximizing different learning
opportunities so our managers our
practitioners come together quite
regularly
and actually we're tipping the learning
into those spaces and having
conversations
and asking them what do you think we
should do about this
issue or does that feel right to you
so we've got much more of an approach to
embracing learning being open to what's
happening and how we can improve it
there any other questions from other
members
i think there's a few hands up david all
right
[Music]
yeah i do have to go along the
the line i can't see you're not all on
the
screen together you see so i've got
um john lamb and
councillor rose thomason
tom and geraldine as well
oh and geraldine yeah yes
okay so um we'll take those three
uh as uh as i've said them and that's
john lamb first
okay thanks chair uh thanks jill for the
uh report which was very comprehensive
and clearly sets out where we are
up to now so i've got two probably basic
questions really um i was just
interested to know
what sorts of think about the pandemic
and looked after
children the children within the scope
of the you know the service
um what sorts of issues are sort of
coming forward in terms of
um you know how they are coping or not
coping uh in this rather difficult time
and then my second point was if i just
put my uh
chair of governors uh of a of a
secondary
school hat on i was just thinking about
how
well we we are working with the schools
i mean i
i think i know what the answer probably
is but um i'd just be interested to
uh to to know you know is that part of
the multi-agency
sort of working arrangements that we
that we have and now we
you know are we picking up those sorts
of issues absolutely
so if i take that second bit first and
then i'll come back to our children in
care
one of the things that has been a real
um strengthening through the pandemic
ironically
has been or working with schools
so some of the things that we have
needed to do is to make sure
particularly when we were in lockdown
that we had
a rapid alert system in terms of any
vulnerable children that weren't in
school
and that we were having conversations
with our
teachers and our schools to say you know
jill mcgregor's not in school
she is somebody that you're working with
and we're really quite worried so as we
could determine who was the best place
person to go and see
that young person and to share
information
and that has been a real strengthening
we've also stood back up our early help
panels
and the schools are very much taking
information to those panels to say
who they will read about so as we can
have a collective
response and as part of our multi-agency
meetings we have been seeing who's been
able to come to the meetings what that's
looked like
and again attendance has been
quite good using the virtual space
really
i touched on the early help developments
and we've actually seconded an ex-head
teacher to be part of our core team to
take forward those early help
developments and i think as a chair of
governor you'll know that
actually teachers talking to teachers
probably carries a lot more weight
than a social worker talking to a
teacher um
and i mean that with the greatest of
respect to my social work staff
but part of what we've done through the
co-design and part of what we're doing
in the
the approach is to value and recognize
the expertise and the knowledge
that every professional has and teachers
know our children really really well
they see the majority of our children
every day
so we need to listen to what they're
saying and i think they're finding that
incredibly helpful so one of the things
that i know
is that in terms of our are
children who have a social worker and
their attendance to schools
at school it's been um
higher than the north west average
higher than the england average
and 1.5
of our children who have a social worker
have been going to school
so just by having that system of
conversations agreeing whether we needed
to have a multi-agency meeting whether
we needed to do a visit that week
how quickly that visit needed to happen
i think there's been a strengthening
is there more to do and will teachers
say
we told you we were worried about this
and you wouldn't accept it as a case
still
yes there'll always be those those
instances
but what i do think is that we've got a
much better shared understanding
of what those issues are and what we
need to do to take them forward
in terms of our children in care and how
they've experienced the pandemic
it's looked different for different
young people and i think you would
expect that
our virtual school has put on a whole
raft of supports and to reach out to our
children
in care and they've also extended that
to children who are open to social care
but
might still be living with their parents
and that's enabled us to have bespoke
packages and bespoke
support as well as some coming together
so some for some of our children they've
actually liked
working in a virtual way better you know
when i when i was a social worker which
is a very long time ago
it used to be you could have some of
your best conversations when you were
driving your car
because somebody didn't have to make a
eye contact with you and they didn't
feel the intensity of it so for some of
our children in care they've quite
enjoyed having
the contact with their social worker in
different ways
but we've said that's okay but we still
need to come and see you
one of the pieces of work that i'm
absolutely delighted with which was a
coming together
um of children's social care and schools
was we recently commissioned a film
and we had an independent film company
come in and that was called transitions
and we had three of our secondary
schools involved in it
and it it wasn't specifically about
children in care but it was about
our children's lived experience during
pandemic
we had a young person that had
special needs and and a level of
disability involved in it
we had some very talented people and we
had some people for whom life was
difficult involved in that piece of work
and if
any of you haven't seen it i would
really encourage you to
to watch it it makes me cry every time i
see it
and what that was all about was
capturing
what what this period felt like for
all young people and i think the
important thing for me now is
so what we as the adults with some
responsibility going to do with some of
their messages and their learning
from that
okay thank you davey before you go on
could i just comment on the film because
i would agree with jill it's an
excellent uh film i i passed it on to my
two heads
uh head teachers and said can we get
this out to our school population
because i thought that
you know it clearly spoke to children to
youngsters of of that age so uh well
done it's a great uh a great
a great film thank you jill
good thank you councillor thompson
thank you chair and thank you for the
report i thought it was really thorough
and lots of information in there i just
want to ask about the recruitment and
retention
you did some work into um
the issues around recruitment and
retention
and i know you've put some measures in
place
to improve that are you seeing are we
bearing any fruit has yet to
what kind of time scales are we looking
at foreign
in terms of that detailed piece of work
that really forensic piece of work we
only concluded it
last week and it has highlighted some
themes
and we absolutely do need to
take all of those recommendations
forward
and one of the things that was really
striking for me
was that there are some underlying
issues there are some themes
and one of one of the things that we
know is that
actually how you look after people how
well they feel supported
is one of the key things um
so we we already had a recruitment and
retention group that was meeting we
already had a detailed plan
in terms of it but now that we've got
this forensic analysis
we need to refresh update
and take forward that plan so in terms
of
of what we've done so far bearing in
mind that it was only completed
about two weeks ago i've already shared
the findings with kath
as lead member because it's really
important that she understands
what we're saying my leadership team
have considered it we updating and
taking the actions forward and i'm
taking it to our practitioners board
in the next couple of weeks to talk to
staff about
this is what we're finding and a little
bit like
the transitions via film the critical
thing is
we've got the information now what do we
need to do about it
so we need to think about
how how welcoming we are to our students
we need to think about how we can grow
our own
we need to think about what our
development opportunities are for our
staff who are with us how how we build
on their excitement
and their enthusiasm because you know
different staff will have different
levels of interest in various things
i hated working with adolescents um
because i wasn't very good at it
whereas some people feel really enthused
and do that really really well and some
people
really like adoption work and like to be
able to support
um children to find their forever family
so we need to harness
what interests people as part of their
career development and aspiration
and so we have a number of actions
already in place but there are some that
we just really need to to think about
from the perspective of
we've we've had this detailed
information
so the information included analysis of
exit interviews
um comparing salaries with other local
authorities
and listening to what our staff were
saying taking the findings of the pulse
survey
age demographics i mean it it really is
a
an incredibly helpful piece of work and
like i say the challenges
for us as the leaders now to listen to
that work and take action
okay uh counselor coggins
thank you yeah thanks yes um i think
cancer lamb has asked some of my
questions uh
having having two heads gives him a
great advantage he dives in with people
and but anyway um the thank you jill for
the report and the update and
and thanks to all the staff who are now
working hard and it's incredibly
difficult and and important and i wanted
to ask a few questions about the case
loads um
it's one of the things i suppose where
those who don't have a deep
understanding of k
of social work can actually see some
figures in that i
seem to remember that we had started
somewhere around 30 and there was an lga
benchmark i think around 20.
and this mentions in the report that
they've improved significantly and i
mentioned at one point they got to 17
but they seem to be creeping up again
and i was just wondering um if we could
have an update on where that is up to
and um and how we are doing in
comparison to lga benchmarks and that
and i also just want to ask about it
mentions the still capacity issues at
senior leadership level
and i wasn't wondering what that really
entails i suppose and and why that is
because obviously we've
um we have been working on that so just
wanted to have some more information
thank you so in terms of caseloads the
average is still under 20 but averages
are just an average and um
that is the critical bit that there is
variance in terms of some teams
both across teams and within teams
so the majority of practitioners do have
case loads below 20.
i do have some people that have case
loads above 20
so we're looking at that on an
individual level
because the first thing we have to do is
say what's the support that that
individual practitioner needs
if they have a case load that's higher
than 20
we've done some work in terms of things
like is that because they haven't had
the opportunity to close a case when
it's safe to do so
and can we give them protected time to
do that
we've also done some analysis in terms
of caseloads
and demand across teams and we have had
some staffing instability
so we still have additional capacity in
order to support that
we are at the moment looking to
temporarily increase our agency staff
recognizing that we have got some
turbulence
and we have got some increased demand
coming through but critically the last
conversation with councillor thompson
in terms of actually stabilizing the
workforce and having the right people
with the right skills
in in place is the best way to manage
um the caseload issue really
so um it
and i think the other bits that i would
say and and if any of my staff were here
they would say it's not just about the
numbers jill it's about
it's about the complexity of the cases
so one of the things that we do
is as well as looking at the numbers the
average and
i take that right down to individual
worker
is what the nature of their case load is
because if you've got
three families that have five children
in them you can very quickly get up to
your figure of 20. does that mean that
that's an excessive caseload
if actually their circumstances are
it means that you're writing the same
reports and you've got the same issues
or actually if it's from a 17 year old
down to a baby you've probably got quite
a diverse
number so we look at numbers of families
numbers of children what type of work
is it a child in need case is it a child
protection case
are we doing active assessments are we
in in
care proceedings as well because there's
something about matching skill
there's something about giving a balance
in terms of what that work
looks like for our practitioners as well
and that's one of the key functions i
think
of your team leader your managers you
know it shouldn't take that
we get a weekly report that says what
that looks like
but i do get a weekly report on on
caseloads geraldine and i do ask
those questions about that doesn't look
right so what are we doing around that
and that's one of the things that i
think my staff would say
they probably feel a forensic level of
scrutiny on
but again it's really really important
to do that
um in terms of the the management
capacity
um two things geraldine obviously um
my two new people that i'm recruiting to
um jude starts on monday and pamela
starts the monday after
so they're not physically here yet
although they have been spending some
keeping in touch time
i think the bigger issue for us is that
we
know that for some people when we
promoted them into positions of team
leader or service manager
we didn't necessarily get right
the this is what the task involves and
this is what the expectation of you is
that actually we need to make sure that
we support
managers as well to learn how to be
managers
and what that that means so
one of the things that we're working
really hard on
is clarifying roles and responsibility
and accountability
but wrapping that around with support
for managers
because you can't just say go and do a
new job and that means you know
everything about it we have to recognize
that we have to help and support our
managers and leaders at every stage
is there any more questions no
no wait a minute
[Music]
yeah um councillor jane dylan
thanks thanks council acton and i just
would like to say i really liked it jill
when you mentioned back to basics
because that's just
something that i really really think is
really important and absolutely
brilliant so thank you for that
can i just start really quickly because
i know we're getting on for time how are
you assessing the outcomes of the
children and the families please
and that's it from me and i think
when i said about the majority of our
indicators at
this moment in time are quantitative not
qualitative it absolutely is an area
that we need to further strengthen
because the ultimate test about whether
what we do makes a difference
is whether our children and families say
it's worked and whether it's made a
difference
so one of the things that we are
starting
to do is to look at how we can do things
called conversational audits
and it's what it says on the tin you go
out and talk to people and say
how was that for you what did that feel
like um
did we get it right what can we do to
further strengthen
so we do have some surveys that go out
but actually
we know most people don't take the time
to fill out a survey and the best way
to get that immediate feedback is to
have that conversation with somebody
so it's definitely an area that we're
really cited on in terms of
of needing to improve
um but it is something that we are
absolutely committed to
because that has to be the ultimate test
about whether it's made a difference
not because we get an offstage judgment
but whether our children and families
say
that was a really good experience and
you've been really helpful to us
we do have some services where that's
already embedded
in the way that they work so um but it's
something that we need to roll out
across all of the service
okay um councillor coggins you've still
got your
hand up for you fine
you should disappear and no sorry that
was from earlier
all right that that's okay right
uh i don't think there are any other
questions
um can i thank uh jill
um and councillor heinz um
i think i think it's been really helpful
um
you know having this update really and
a lot of work has been done um
but there's a lot to be done as well so
um
i think that that's recognized from
everything that you've said um
but it does seem to be a good level of
progress that is being made um
i just and i'm not clear when the next
off they did
visit we should have had a monitoring
visit
in march but as i said that was because
what they've done
now is they they aren't implementing
monitoring visits they're undertaking
what they're calling assurance visits
and those assurance visits will
take the form of a focus visit which in
effect will be
a three-week inspection for us um
we do any time i was kind of
my my prediction had been that we would
get it on the 2nd of november but that
would have meant we'd have got a call on
on tuesday and we didn't so
who knows anytime so it's
imminent and and the other bit that i'm
really clear about and we're working on
is that actually any inspection
is just an external validation of what
you're doing and we're working really
hard
with the staff to to make that a reality
yeah but i think it'd be useful
obviously
once that um you know inspection
happens that we we do get another report
i know it'll be reported to the council
as well
to be useful for scrutiny i think to
to have a report and you know to update
it on that
visit um okay then well can i thank you
you know you know so much for
coming tonight and uh you know
sharing that uh update to us
i think it's been very very valuable and
i think the other thing that i'd like to
say
is you know to thank um all the staff
for all the work that they've done
particularly
you know through throughout this
pandemic period
but prior to that as well and uh
you know so um it worked so
very hard i believe and uh you know they
deserve our
thanks so i'd like you to pass that on
[Music]
right okay then um we now move on to
the public health and adult social care
which was
six but it's become seventh
item on the agenda and this is in three
parts
um a public health um
an adult social care update and
the health services
just to say for the health services we
do have
um in attendance uh martin pritchard who
is the accountable officer for the
trafford ccg and naomi ledward
director of commissioning for traffic
ccg
um but that's the third part so we'll we
will start
at the um public health uh update
and um we have the executive member for
health and well being who is jane slater
and um the equalities
i'm sorry and eleanor well for director
of public health
services so um so i don't know who's
going to
start uh is it councillors later or
yeah they're going to interrupt we
should we just also welcome
other uh yeah yeah i meant to do that
actually yeah
yeah sorry yeah yeah i i will absolutely
do that i've written it down here and
i've
just missed it on my paper so i'm really
sorry about that but
yes also a welcome to heather fairfield
who is the chair of the trafford health
watch
um you know to to this meeting and and
hopefully
for future meetings as well because i
think um
uh i i know heather does a lot of work
in terms of
uh and it's you know voluntary work
in terms of uh keeping an eye on all
health matters um in in in trafford and
i think
uh you know that's tremendous work that
she does
so i know you are there because i've
seen yeah yeah thank you
yeah so so thanks very much for
coming and i'm sorry that i um you know
missed that introduction but uh you
you you are most welcome as always thank
you
right so can we just go to the um
uh councillor jane slater
future and no we should never forget
heather
and thank you and we've been doing you
know quite a lot of work obviously
um in trafford and we've been looking
you know with the hospitals around how
we um
are going to make it safe for people to
be able to go and have those
um services that were stepped down at
the beginning of covet so i know that
martin and
naomi will be able to give you some
further information around that
obviously
ellen is going to be able to give us an
update of where we are and around public
health and what track and trace and
stuff looks like currently
and and you'll all be aware that you
know from midnight tonight we go into
tier three so there will be new cons
around what tier three looks like so you
know
it's uh it's an ever-changing feast and
and then you know hopefully that
you know we're plateauing with
infections with across trafford but i'll
elena
and give the latest information thank
you chair yeah
thanks jane helena
okay thank you very much for inviting me
um
i know um so we um
our levels do seem to be leveling off
slightly
um unfortunately this is because our
our rates in our late teenagers and
people in their early twenties are
starting to drop
so that was that student population we
started to see very high rates in um
in september in the middle of october
and we are
now seeing an increase in our rates in
our
people age 65 and all over which is
obviously the
the group that we are most concerned
about because they are the people who
are most likely to be seriously affected
if they get covered and in fact we are
now seeing our hospitalization rates
going
up um i think one thing about the
hospitalization rates
is that the hospitalization rates are
determined by the number of people who
became
infected or ill two or three weeks ago
so with the rates we're seeing now we
are going as we see those rates go up we
will see the
rise in hospitalizations coming forward
in the next two or three weeks so you
know i think when um
and the nhs is very is very well
equipped and and
has coped and will cope but to say that
we
are that we shouldn't worry about it
because we're not seeing the
hospitalization rates yet
um that actually these people are if you
like we don't know which of them will
end up in hospital
but some of the people who have been
affected over the last couple of weeks
will end up in hospital over the next
couple of weeks
so we really do need to be doing
absolutely everything we can
to try and get the rates down in this
older population
and because most people over 65 live
um absolutely fit and healthy lives
living in the community and so on
we can't get the rates down in that
population unless we also get the rates
down in the rest of the population
um very sadly we've seen a couple of
outbreaks recently in care homes we've
done incredibly well
more recently in in keeping cases out of
care homes but i think with the levels
of
covert that we have in our general
population uh
we will really struggle to keep that out
of the care homes because however hard
those care home workers try and however
much the cajon managers work
if you're you know when you when you're
coming in to work from a household where
there are other people of all ages you
you know you really will struggle to
with that so um
the other issues that we have in traffic
remaining issues as you know
we still continue to see these very high
rates across the board we
our highest rates are currently in
clifford ward and hale barnes
and i think that just tells you
everything you need to know about
traffic
covered in traffic it is absolutely
everywhere
there's very little that those two
awards if you if you you know they're
not our most deprived than our most
affluent but they're nearly
um so it is that difference that we're
seeing and we have rates
over 400 per hundred thousand in all
four of our fauna
in all four trafford localities so we
really are seeing
very widespread only two wards with
rates of less than 200 per hundred
thousand
so this is a this is something that we
need to be dealing with as ivara
as trafford this is absolutely all of us
that it is affecting
um i'm not going to go through the
detail
at the um report in detail and i'm very
happy to take
any questions but on the testing we have
still seen some issues with delayed
results
but we seem to have much better access
at the moment we are a bit concerned
that the rate of people going for
testing is dropping
and we're slightly worried that this is
because of publicity about
the link with the police get it being
given test and trace
data and this is something that i think
from public health perspective i would
be very concerned about sharing that
data
i think it's most important that we get
that engagement with our population and
they have the trust in us to come and
have
have a test if they're symptomatic um
our positivity rate remains high
and isn't decreasing um so that suggests
that we
are not it's not that we're seeing fewer
people being tested because we
have fewer cases um so that is a worry
for us
our contact tracing um is working well
locally but again
the national issues with the testing and
the delays and the contact tracing are
still problematic
um and i think the national contact
racing they do make an awful lot of
calls to people actually talking to
somebody the other day
who through her household they had had
42 calls from test and trace
over that two week period i mean that
would try the patience of a saint to be
honest
um so i think there's some things we
need to be uh talking to the national
system about
um how we improve that locally we pick
up the cases
when um other when the national system
hasn't been able to
contact them in many cases they are
completely uncontactable but we are
getting through to people that other
that the national system hasn't been
able to reach so we are doing well on
that
and a lot of our time at the moment is
being spent through the contact racing
work on working with
schools and other settings such as
businesses to
um support um particularly the schools
and the head teachers in identifying
who who you know when if there's a case
in the school whether a bubble needs to
be suspended and so on
we've had um in the main our cases and
schools have been community acquired and
aren't we're not seeing a lot of
transmission within the school
but one piece of learning that we've had
from workplace settings and from
um and from our school space work
is and if there's one message that i
would really love it if you're forgiving
this um call could
take home and spread to everybody they
know which is
if you have symptoms and you have a test
you must stay at home
until you have the results of that test
your family must also stay at home until
those results come in
because if you go back to work or if you
go to school while you're waiting for
the results
then if you get a positive test
everybody that you've seen that day when
you were waiting
is going to be if you've come into close
contact with them all of those people
will have to self-isolate
and none of those people will be happy
with you
so please please if you are waiting for
a test
please do not go anywhere just stay at
home with your family for that time
the second issue i think that people
have got and i this one i mean i think
those are confusing
but this the second issue is if you
found somebody in your family has a test
and you're told to self-isolate then
it's no point you going for a test
unless a
doctor tells you to if you don't have
symptoms
if you don't have symptoms you the test
result may well come back negative
but that you still have to self-isolate
because you could be incubating the
disease
so again it's just that message about
please if you know
maintain that self-isolation because
that's the way to break the transmission
because the thing with this is you're
infectious before you know you've got it
so the only way we can stop that is
getting in early and helping people
isolate
and i suppose the final thing i want to
talk to links to that which is the
community engagement work and that's the
next big piece of work that we're
going to be trying to do in trafford
we've got um
people going around in north trafford
tomorrow um talking to
particularly mosque leaders we've got
translated materials but also into shops
and businesses
just trying to make sure that everybody
has that message we'll be doing similar
work in the other
localities because obviously we do have
these high rates
across the board and most of our
transmission
we suspect is just people generally
mixing with other people
going out in groups i think i think
sometimes as well when people hear about
household mixing
they think it means your whole household
mixing with another
whole household but of course if you
live in a house with four or five people
and each one of you may go out with
different groups of people
and so you can quite quickly get a very
wide spread
if one of you is infected just because
you're seeing more people
and between you so we're really pushing
that
um i mean obviously we're here three
that there's more limitation on on what
people can do
but it's actually we're really trying to
push the message about you know
absolutely get some exercise see people
but do it outside go for a walk in a
park
um keep those two meters distance and
really do not go into anyone's house
do not invite anyone into your house
so i think that's that's what i wanted
to update i think you may have heard
lots of that already but
no effect thanks very much um
no i'll open it up for questions now and
i i do have
uh dr karen barkley
and councillor barry winston so
karen thank you uh chair and i thank you
elena so much for
that very helpful presentation i just
have uh two questions and first one is
about the
issue of fines and the police um getting
involved i mean i think that
is a very damaging message and i think
you acknowledge that yourself and
i just wondered what can we do and kind
of as
a borough to counteract that because i
do fear that
people won't come forward i mean i i
read that nationally it may be
accounting for the fact that the number
of young people
and particularly students are not coming
forward because of that concern so
how can we counterbalance that because
that is such a dangerous
development and the other point i just
like to have some clarification on
please is
last time we met we did um hear that
there might be some movement towards a
more locally based
contact tracing uh system which we know
would be incredibly
helpful and probably um engage a lot
more people and we'd find more
more cases more contacts do you know how
far
uh plans for that have developed and how
well equipped are we
uh to do that should it become
implemented thank you
okay so i'll start with the fines and i
completely agree with you i think
my understanding of the legislation
around the fines
with the contact racing is it's up for
local areas to implement that so
um i don't know what we can do with the
national part of it but i think
certainly from speaking to colleagues in
greater manchester
i haven't heard anyone who has any
appetite to start introducing that in
greater manchester
so um we would not be wanting i would
not be wanting to share
our local data with the police um
because i just think
it makes it very very difficult to get
the trust of the population
not that um i think we will there will
definitely be cases where we will
issue fines but those will be in
much more i would suspect they're likely
to be in um
if you like quite outlier cases and
we're perhaps with businesses where we
um where we
i mean with the businesses we have had
to close some businesses issues
directions to close businesses because
of non-compliance
so i think but but really i mean in this
country with police by consent don't we
and when we've got the rates of
infection that we're seeing
we all need to be thinking about how we
change our behavior and
do it trying to enforce it when it's
about households and how households
behave
is really you're on a hiding to nothing
um we need to
we need to work with our communities so
that they can understand
what what it is we're trying to do why
we're trying to do it and
most importantly how can we support
people what if they have to self-isolate
and how can we support people so that
their mental health and physical health
remains good through what is going to be
i think a very difficult winter
and threatening people isn't going to
help get that engagement we have to get
that engagement
through conversation through discussion
through negotiation
um on the locally based contact racing
there are greater plans for greater
manchester and as we're now in tier
three there is additional funding that
will be coming through integrated
manchester to support with that
so that's the eight pounds ahead that
you may have heard about
so we're looking at what we need to be
doing locally around contact tracing and
how that fills into the greater
manchester approach
but the other thing i would say is with
the rates we've got at the moment
we're not going to contact trace our way
out of this at the moment
we're seeing over 110 people on average
a day testing positive
we can't possibly if you think of each
of those people if they're being honest
with us about how many contacts they've
had
particularly when people are working and
so on you know that can be up to 30
people
we cannot contact trace all of those
people
without an absolute army of contact
races and it's just not an efficient way
of working what we need to do is sort it
out at the source
and help get that prevention in to make
sure that all of our businesses
all of our workplaces and all of our
population are understanding how to be
covered safe and that's that's the
message we've got to get
through to people that people have some
control over this themselves
can i just follow up on that
because i think obviously
there's been a lot uh talked about
testing and tracing there's been a kind
of panacea
um of getting out of this and and what
you're saying
tonight is that that's not the case
um it's impossible
so so i think i think
you know that what i've been hearing on
the news quite a lot is that if if we
get
a good test and trend then
um you know we won't need to have all
the
kind of lockdown we're experiencing
well the trouble is that you'd have to
test and track so many people if you
think that everybody if you
to do it effectively where it works is
where you've got
a low rate in your general population
and then you can quickly get on top of
any infection
and isolate it from everyone else but
when you've got 300 people
um per 100 000 testing positive
when you've got 110 people every day
coming forward
every day who are positive and then you
have to
isolate all of those households etcetera
you quite quickly get to a situation
where you don't actually have a
workforce anymore
because if you're doing it all by test
and trace people are all
self-isolating and so on and this is
what we've seen some of the cases we've
seen in schools is not is because
we're having to close down whole bubbles
and classes and that means the teachers
and their families are then isolating
all the children
isolating and that means parents have to
stay at home looking after their
children and i'm sure there are people
on the school
who've been in that situation one way or
another um
and so you know you quite quickly get to
a situation where
actually it's not it's not going to be
the way forward whereas if we can
i mean public health person i'm going to
say prevention is better than cure
if we can make sure that people take the
steps they need to make themselves safer
and that we work with our businesses and
our workplaces
and our schools which we have been doing
fantastic work in schools and businesses
to make them covered secure then we're
much less likely to have the outbreaks
so what we need to do is get the rates
down once the rates are down
really quick access to testing to anyone
who's positive
really quick contact tracing of those
people you know if you've got a four day
delay
in getting your test results by the time
you've got those test results
the people that you might have infected
before you knew you were ill
in those two days before you even went
for the test because you didn't know you
were ill
those people are starting to develop
symptoms that may have infected somebody
else
so you know unless you get those tests
done really quickly
and you get the contact tracing done
really quickly it's not going to work
and it won't work on big numbers so
i think you didn't try to do something i
think it's interesting how you how you
spelt it out
because it's not necessarily the message
that is
getting through to the public you know
and and
it seems to be the that is a national
you know if we get a a world-class
test test and track then you know
that'll
solve all the problems but it's not you
know
and i quite understand why um
but but i think it's useful just to have
it spelt out
um yeah okay um who else have we got
um i've written it down somewhere
oh yeah uh counselor barry winston
yeah thank you chair and thank you
enough for that crystal clear report and
um and i couldn't agree more with the
point about
finding people yeah anyone who's ever
managed anybody knows
the best way you get the best out of
people by working with them
continually kicking them is the wrong
way to do is the wrong way to do
anything
um i might just return to the um uh
the the tracking bit the reports i read
that with some horror that the
uh that the national the national data
is not in any way shape or form robust
and assume that
the national data is coming out of the
eucharistic
nhs system which is in fact the circo
system when we spend 12 billion quid on
is it that it is that system which is
not producing the right set of data
isn't it
and i was just horrified to see that the
we're having to put local resource into
data mining to to make sure that that
data is
in any way shape or form usable
particularly in the context when we're
being denied funds for greater
manchester we've been denied funds for
um the funds to feed our kids to spend
12 billion pounds on a system which
doesn't work strikes me as just
absolutely monstrous but however
the real the the question i'm leading up
to is when you're when you're dealing
with
the the circle teams or whoever you're
whoever you're dealing with
to look at this data what are their
reactions when you you tell them that
the data is not uh fit the purpose
because i assume they're the kind of
contractual conversations that you will
have
so that was that was a little builder
but walking back was a quite
straightforward question sorry about
that
so we don't have the contractual um
arrangements obviously with either the
testing organizations or the
um the national test nhs testing traits
those are both nationally um commission
services
so we don't we do but what we do is
where we have issues with the testing
service or with them so for example we
will often report back to
the vhsc if we have issues with care
homes not getting the tests they need
so we make sure that where there are
issues we report them back in
those are being reported as well
repeatedly up by
through public health england and
through other colleagues so those
reports do get in but
they're not our they're not our
contracts so we don't actually have um
any uh ability to renegotiate them
in terms of the pest and trace i think
the national system i think some of the
inefficiencies are the fact that they
they could if they didn't keep needing
to ring people so many times they could
probably ring more people
and i think and i do feel quite sorry
for them because of course the
bad press that they've got has meant
that people have lost faith in it and
people
aren't aren't speaking to them and in a
way some of that isn't their fault
certainly it's not the fault of the
people doing the phone calls
um so my my main urging is for people to
to if you are in contact by nhs
testimonies please please please do
engage with them
please do self please do take it
seriously
because it's really important and they
are just doing their job
we get the data through and we will
follow up and
we would like to do that more quickly
and um and i do think
uh you know obviously in a local area
you do know your local areas and you're
able to engage more easily with people
if somebody says
to me oh i live in sale or oh i live in
hale or i live in
um burswood or whatever i know
immediately what that means don't i but
if i was in a
if i was in a call center in warrington
not even warrington you know essex say i
wouldn't i wouldn't know what that meant
and i wouldn't maybe make those links
so i think it is that we just need to
make sure that whatever we do
and how we're doing it now we build
better and we get a better system so
that we're able to get that data through
quickly
and we're able to contact people quickly
and at the moment
i really feel that we need to be um
for all the frustrations with the
national system it's better that we try
and support it
because it is part it's a really
important part of the system
and the more trust we get in the whole
system the more likely it is we'll get
on
under all of this under control thank
you
thanks okay i think um
that's it for questions for now um
okay can i thank you helena uh
for all the work that you and your staff
do i say every time but uh
i really do mean it um but but thank you
for that update
it's it's been very helpful um thank you
thank you we just move on to adult
social
care um and we have councillor
harding the executive member for adult
social
care and diane eaton who is the
corporate director
of adult services
um yeah there you are
yeah thanks chair um i'm going to bring
diane
in to talk through the detail of the
winter plan because i think it's
important obviously as diana's our
director of adult social services to
talk through some of the
operational detail but i think um i just
wanted to pick up on a couple of points
that eleanor mentioned and referenced
specifically around some of the
infection rates
in care homes um that is something that
obviously i will be keeping
um a watching eye on and in close
contact with diane
and her team clearly it's something that
we've been um
keeping an eye on since the start of the
pandemic and we were
um very proud at the beginning that we
we made sure that we had all the testing
in place
and but as things have changed and we
are going into
a second wave and staff
you know potentially being asymptomatic
in issues with test results coming back
and so on
we are sadly starting to see some of
those positive results
so i just want you to be aware that as a
pandemic
scrutiny committee always happy to come
back and
feed information on what the care home
sector is looking like
and it's really important that we keep
an eye over the winter period
i guess the other thing i would raise
about adult social care and
care homes in particular and not just
for older people
is that you will all be aware of the
restrictions around visits
and some families have not seen their
families for
months and months and this is an ongoing
issue and as we move into tier three
those restrictions are still in place
around visits um i'm working really
closely
with the alzheimer's society with diane
and her team
and with northwest adas and across
greater manchester there's been
an options appraisal paper written so
that we can try and look at some um
ways that we can try and see if we can
facilitate visits in a very safe way
potentially looking at testing the use
of
ppe so that's also being raised at a
national
as well as a regional um level so those
are some of the key
areas around adult social care but again
just to remind you that
the visits that also looks at younger
people who are potentially in
supported living with living with
learning disability people with mental
health issues
so it isn't just older people in care
homes it does cross
a range a range of people really so i'll
hand over to diane to talk through the
winter plan
but as always i i'm very happy to take
any questions on the issues
i've raised too thanks chair thank you
john
thank you chair um i'm not going to put
the presentation up check
i know that obviously the um time is an
issue
and but i'm just going to pick out some
points on slides for the committee to
to consider and on slide three you'll
see some
modeling so we've been doing a massive
amount of work looking at the first wave
and then the differences with the second
wave of the
virus on the first wave we had people
who were
considerably older who were affected had
long uh
numerous long-term conditions and their
their journey into hospital and their
length to stay in hospital was
considerably long
so 10 to 12 weeks on average so when
people were ready to go home the
services they need were quite different
from the phase that we're going into so
we've got a lot of younger people
who will recover a lot faster and we'll
need to go home with home
support so we've been remodeling all of
the both bed based and support
at home that we require on slide four it
sets out all
guidance and the legislation that's been
issued and the requirements to complete
an adult social care winter plan
and an nhs wave three response plan
and which includes all of the step up of
business as usual
elective surgery etc which martin's on
and we'll speak to
later we've agreed to trafford we'll
we'll have one plan because it's too
confusing to have more than one so we
have one collective integrated plan as
we always would do
on the further slides on fire on slide
five it sets out some of the challenges
winter is always a complex time for
adult social care and for our health
colleagues
and just because of the sheer demand
ether slips and falls flues etc
however with covid as that added um
overarching concern this winter
we are planning for a long and difficult
time
the path of our approach on slide six
and take in account of all of the phase
three work which is the business as
usual and restart the electric work
the winter capacity planning that we
would normally do anyway
and the surge planning based on what
we've seen from the coving
infection and trajectories we then
brought that across on slide seven
into adult social care and looking at
how we then also look at aspects of
preventing the spread of um the virus in
our care settings and i'd include not
just care homes but people living
at home particularly where they have
vulnerabilities
and how we work as a system across
health and social care and with our
partners in the voluntary sector
and other services to collaborate to
make sure that we've got the right
support in place going into
the winter period we um
we've worked really really hard with our
colleagues in the hospitals to ensure
that we can facilitate the right
capacity and community
to help people go home quickly should
they need to go into hospital or more
importantly if they don't need to go in
how we support them at home
to remain as well as possible and get
the right medical support as well as
social care input
on slide 8 our trafford local care
organization responses detail there for
you
they've been tracking their capacity in
district nursing and therapy support
in our social work provision as well and
each of the pathways that we have
developed are attached as a separate
document for you to see and it breaks
down how
the journey of support is is put
together
across health and social care and then
the services we have in place to respond
to that
we have a whole program of work set up
to deliver these changes
and we refresh the requirements based on
intelligence that we receive on a weekly
and daily basis
back through eleanor's team and other
sources we've worked very closely with
mft
and looking at the actual activity in
each of our hospital sites
and then how we need to respond going
forward
hospital discharge policies that we've
been running since the beginning of
covid based on the change legislation
have been updated because the
legislation
and guidance changed in august with a
funding change from the first of
september so from
at that date anybody leaving hospitals
funded
by the nhs for a six-week period
um after which they moved it to the
long-term funding
for any care and we've done all of that
work together and we've actually set
some of the
national trends on how people will work
in the future
across health and social care around
assessment
we've commissioned um numbers of
discharged recessed beds which are
temporary beds in our care homes
which support people who just need a
little bit more recovery time before
they go home
we've done masses of work with the homes
and with our providers to make sure
that any infection risks are managed
really carefully
so we are very very clear that people
leaving hospital are tested
before they leave hospital they have
temperature tests for 48 hours prior to
leaving
and they have to be below a certain
level before we'll accept them into our
care homes
you will know recently that we went out
to tenders to look for some beds
and for people who were covered positive
on discharge from hospital
and we are currently negotiating with
manchester around a specific provider
cqc have introduced a inspection
requirement
for those types of homes and once we
have commissioned that service we will
submit
who uh cqc and that inspection will take
place alongside manchester
united and we're also commissioning
additional rapid
uh discharge support to support people
in their own homes and that process is
underway
and our colleagues in health around
therapy and nursing support
are also increasing capacity in the
areas that the modeling indicates we
need it
obviously there are some key risks over
the winter period not just the
risk that i've talked about on the
normal winter but all of the increased
um infection activity and responses that
we're needed to make
our supply to homes for things like ppe
and which you will have heard a lot in
the press we have very good supply we
track through our commissioning team
twice a week with every provider to
check that they have supplies of
everything
that they have no other issues that we
need to support them with
and we also talk about their long-term
um requirements
uh for support we have a couple of areas
that we're
exploring with that with um colleagues
across uh
in the ccg which is the support for
people who have got long-term impacts
postcovid
you will have heard of long covered on
the news being referred to that's the
sort of long-term breathing or mobility
issues
that it tends to leave people with and
that work is progressing we haven't
um sourced all the services we would
like yet but we are working across
greater manchester nationally around
some of those responses
one of the biggest concerns for me i
think is people that do not
um seek medical help quickly enough
and therefore uh enter our services at a
much later point than they would have
done
there's a lot of work being done with
ellen's teams and with our
colleagues across health and social care
to get those messages out to people
and the early indication of any medical
uh situation
is much much preferred for your for your
own health but also
to ensure that we can manage the support
quickly and effectively
we've got some great examples of of work
that our care providers have done
we've got oxymeters in care homes so
people are able to take oxygen
checks from people and liaise with
primary care
we've got enhanced clinical care support
into all our care homes
make sure that people are well supported
and
the the winter plan itself is around 50
pages long
and this is a summary and hopefully
we'll give you an overview of the work
that we're doing
to ensure the residents of trafford are
supported well through the winter
thank you chair thanks very much diane i
think that was
a pretty good run-through of
what you're doing
is there any questions from members
no questions
[Music]
i think you must have covered everything
pretty well
to be honest thank you thank you if
there are any questions if people let me
know
yeah we we definitely will do that but
thank you and i and i i really do think
because obviously every day is a
different day at the moment isn't it and
i think trying to keep the pandemic out
of the homes
it is critical and crucial and i think
you
you know you look as though you're doing
everything that you possibly can
to avoid really grateful for
you know that yeah can i just
can i just add something chair yeah um
i've seen something circulating on
social media again from amnesty
international
today that mentions about a leaked
report around
positive tests and care homes which
um i know we've had this discussion
before around the channel four
news piece um i just wanted again to
reassure the committee
that you know that we do have those
testing processes in place
but i do think it's important to
reiterate that there will be people who
test positive who still need the support
of social care services
so we need to be really clear about that
that we have a statutory duty of care
to provide care who will be positive
with covid so we have to be careful
not to demonize people who test positive
two and make sure that we don't set the
hairs running
amongst people who might have to you
know place their family
in a care setting so we're managing that
very very carefully we're trying to make
sure the messaging
is very sensitive about that but if any
of you do see those reports and are
concerned
we we are very transparent and open
about how we manage that and we'd much
prefer you to come directly to us
and ask those questions rather than set
up you know all that the panic that
happened last time
thank you yeah no thanks for that joanne
i think
it's it's a really good point that you
make and
you know it is a statutory duty and you
know we
we've got to do the best that we can for
every individual within the care homes
i think that's exactly what we're trying
to do yeah so
i'd like to you know thank all the staff
and all the care homes really for all
the work that they
have been doing through this pandemic
so if you now go on to the health
services um
we've got for this item as i said
earlier on
uh martin pritchard and the the
accountable officer for the
trafford ccg and naomi ledward
uh director of commissioning for shaffer
and you've been very
trafficked uh ccg and you've been very
patient um but i'm really pleased that
you you've come along
uh today um i don't know who's going to
help to go through this update
so chair if it's okay if i start and
then i'm going to
that would be great thank you and
thanks for inviting me this evening it's
been a while since i've been to
um to scrutiny with these new
arrangements so
um first of all i'd just like to say
how well um i feel that diane and elena
have worked to
support the health service in in
trafford and it's
absolutely been a real partnership
between health and social care
all the way through this and continues
to to be
i think uh david chair sorry um you said
that every day
um sometimes it feels like it's the same
day repeating itself
um there is a bit of an element of
groundhog day with us at the moment but
absolutely we've been
absolutely joined together all the way
through this and i'm sure we will be
however long it takes to get through
this so you've asked us to talk about
the health service response in this in a
moment i'm going to hand over to my
colleague
naomi who's going to do this um what
what i've
found from all the other times that i've
been to scrutiny if we do a very
short presentation and then we can
answer your questions and focusing on
the areas that you absolutely want to
focus in on so i'm going to hand over to
naya and then
we'll we're both here to answer all of
your questions
thank you chair excellent thanks very
much martin
thank you so justin i'll follow that
we're down and maybe not put my slides
up but take you through the points of
the slides because i think martin point
martin's point is correct it's um
we're giving you a very high level
overview of
what the services the ccg commissions
has done in response to covid
and i'm sure that will stimulate some
more questions which we can either
answer tonight or we can take offline
and come back to you as well
um so the first bit is around
general practice um and what has
happened within general practice so
in the initial phases of covid and
we worked with the practices to make
sure they were all prepared it's
you know the the priority here is to
ensure that we
sustain the workforce make sure that
we've got the doctors and nurses and
healthcare practitioners to be able to
support people to stay well but also
to give access to people in a cfy so the
initial
the initial phases were to work to
ensure that every practice was able to
respond and were prepared
and we took steps um initially right at
the start of covert to
introduce a total triage model which
very much changed how everybody has
access gps i'm sure
most of us around here have probably
been to gp during the pandemic
um and initial triage is known face to
face and then that determines whether
people need to come into surgery or can
be dealt with over the phone
and there has been um a real move within
trafford which actually happened before
the pandemic around digitalization as
well
so the use of ask my gp and giving
people alternative ways of being able to
contact
their gp at any r of the day really to
be honest
and which has has made a difference we
supplied it support to the gps
to ensure that they could work from home
and just going back to the case we were
talking about before you know if you're
if you're socially isolating or if you
have to you've been contacted by track
and trace
we don't want to take out the the
workforce in in that case so
we supplied additional it equipment to
enable that to happen
and and set up dedicated clinics for
those patients that are described with
um as hot or those that are described
with having covered symptoms
that being that they could come into a
dedicated hot service or be visited at
home if they if they couldn't get into
the service as well
and goes without saying there was a
robust plan around ppe
supplies and to ensure that we kept our
workforce protected
and also we took a very flexible
approach to how the gp contract
was um laid out and allowed gps to
um flex the services they have in the
capacity they have to meet the demand
rather than what was really stipulated
you know per day per hour within the
contract
and we also had a suite of priority
pathways and that's probably a
demonstration of how closely we work
with diane
and eleanor because diane's mentioned
that within her presentation
so the gps weren't just working alone
they were working with their partners
across the system
and the discharge to assess pathways and
the virtual wards
end of life support support within care
homes
and urgent care provision as well so
there were there was wrap around
services to support the gps
and access to testing we also redeployed
our own staff
and stepped down some of the services we
were working on
to go and support and keep frontline
services running within
the gp practices so moving on to this
next phase of recovery
and we're very much looking at how the
networks how gps can work together
and to be resilient particularly as
we're now testing wider and workforce
fluctuations may happen
and we have a winter plan which
integrates directly into the winter plan
that diane was talking about which
covers the flu vaccination program
which eleanor will know much more about
than i do
um and also we're managing
normal service is being um put in place
in light of lessons learned from covert
so for example having one practice and
to look after one care home
rather than multiple practices to look
after a care home
and just moving on then to
mental health the majority of mental
health services
stayed um operational during covid
and they may have changed how they
worked and they may have changed in
in the timings of being able to access
and but they did stay they did stay open
and the the mental health providers are
working with us to make sure that they
are planning for the increased demand
and expected complexity that um
will come as a result of covert and the
impact that that has
hazard on our population and also
um there are some very specialist pieces
of work around
mental health so the providers across
manchester and wider are working
together in a mutual aid approach to
make sure that they can support each
other should
there be constraints within an
individual provider
and there's been a real focus on care in
the community
rather than in patient care because the
safest place for someone is within their
own home rather than a ward where we
could spread more and covert around
and so there's been a focus of of
moving the services to be able to
provide that care within home
crisis response at the front door to be
able to give that crisis response and
try to prevent people being admitted
into hospital
and also help line a 24 7 helpline to
recognize that there may be some
low-grade issues
that people would want to contact and
get into the health service through that
way as well
and in terms of hospital recovery so
what we call the elective program which
is just basically planned operations
was you know it was very publicly known
that that was stepped down right at the
start of the of the pandemic
to enable the hospitals to respond
to the growing demand and since then the
focus has been on recovery so we have
lots of system groups and working groups
and with mft who is our main provider
looking at how we can recover
and stand up elective and diagnostic and
cancer activity
this is through basically just standing
the services back up but also by using
new and innovative ways of working so
much more digital access
and having advice and guidance lines for
gps to be able to contact rather than
referring patients in
and also clinical validation so working
and speaking to patients to understand
if
they actually still want the operation
that still need it where they're at
how severe they are and how we can
support them
there is a really big challenge though
so the weights are longer
we're we're looking at um 50 to people
waiting over 52 weeks to be
around um the the six six thousand mark
by um by march which is a very huge
number
but we are working with the provider to
be able to validate that
work with the patients to understand how
we could manage it in different ways
but it is a legacy of covert that we do
have longer weights than we had before
in terms of urgent care the activity
significantly reduced during covert
and during the lockdown period but it's
actually now
increasing back up to pre-pandemic
levels
which as we hit a second wave is having
an impact on the ability of the
hospitals to be able to respond
so again there's lots of work going on
to think about how can we give people
who really need access to urgent care
that access but prevent queuing within
waiting rooms and
and do similar to how the gps have
worked so we have
um digital access through 111 and what
we're calling a local clinical
assessment service
which will hear and treat and see and
treat
patients digitally and we'll be able to
book them into services
so the urgent care services that we
would have had previously where you
wouldn't have been able to book into
we can go through those services and
book into them which means that people
don't have to then wait in waiting rooms
they have
allocated slots and it's much safer for
the staff and the patients as well
and and then i'm just sorry i just got
lost in my slide there
rather than going on to the next one in
terms of community it links
very much to what um diane was
mentioning before
there was a step down of the community
services again in line with national
requirements to
mobilize the first covert response but
since then they have been stepping back
up services
focusing greatly on the work that dan's
been supporting around discharge to
assess
and and therapy within um the community
and also providing access to equipment
as well because we've seen
um an increased need for therapy in um
post coved as well so
and also the community services are also
focusing on how they can
do um online digital access as well
so i'll stop there and pause
see what questions you want to ask and i
think martin and i will probably do a
bit of a double act on the
on the answers back on those great stuff
thank you very much for that
introduction really and i
i think uh the fact that we received
this
um you know before the meeting um
and it's very simple to actually read
and i think you know
there are so many issues in there and
having it very simply you know in a
simple format like that
it's very beneficial for for us uh
because
obviously we we get a lot to read and i
think it's
when you get something simple it's
easier
for your own mind to sort of register
all the issues
so thanks very much for that much
appreciated
um counselor rose thompson
[Music]
thank you chair can i ask a question
about the mental health recovery and the
mental health urgent care centers
mentioned in your slides i i
don't believe these are operational at
the moment are they but
what are the plans to start up these
emergency urgent care centers and what
will it look like
please so i i i don't think as um
as a patient it will look very much
different than what we have now
it's just about making sure people are
aware and understand that this access is
here
so um they will be co-located within
um a e departments or urgent care
departments
and it's effectively whenever um someone
makes
contact or turns up at these um
at these centers it there's a triage or
a streaming at the front end to identify
need
and then it will be streaming the
patients directly into those services
kind of traditionally you would have
maybe sat on a e for a bit to wait for
the mental health team to cut them down
to see you this is more about kind of
front ending
about streaming and being able to get
you there quicker
so it's not really new it's just a
different
it's lessons learned from covert really
it's it's a different way of doing what
we've always
always had really and hopefully making
that better but i think it's about
people understanding that those access
points are there as well
so we are starting to do publicity and
comms
now across the system you will see it
over the next month or so
and it will be national as well and to
to
let people know that there are these
places that they can go to to seek help
you
okay counselor dr karen barton
thank you thank you chairman uh could i
just ask about um
using uh the nightingale hospital that
we have uh within uh
well not within the borough but within
greater manchester what is the
likelihood of using that either for
treating covert patients and therefore
freeing up the hospitals
or for using it to treat covid patients
so the hospitals have their own
space back again thank you
you want me to answer that martin is
that okay
um i think it's i can think i can safely
say no i mean you know much more about
the nightingale than i did haven't been
involved setting it up in the first
place
yes i think so can i just okay can i
just add to that really yeah
that that question and i'll try you know
roll it up in one railing and are you
gonna cope in the hospitals
um because it's pressure that um
you know it looks as though it's gonna
come under that worse
in a couple of weeks or so yeah so i'll
add i'll
i'll do that second part as well so yes
there are plans to
to reopen the nightingale to be a
resource just for
the initial period for manchester and
trafford it will be a
36 bedded unit and and it will be
predominantly for
covert negative patients who will be
stepping down who need more rehab
um therapy and support so as martin
alluded to i helped set the nightingale
up in the first wave of it and it was
very much the more acute patients who
were needing
um oxygen and cpap and and more
intensive care
this is looking about supporting
patients because we know the demographic
is going to be people needing longer
rehab and support so we can move them to
a safe place
that they can get that support that
frees up the hospital capacity
so i think the the short answer to the
second part of the question chair is
the hospitals will cope um but they're
having to flex and adapt their plans
very regularly
i go to the mft strategic meeting three
times a week and hear that happening
live and also the hospitals are working
together across gm
and what we call a mutual aid approach
so they have
um done modeling about the impact so um
eleanor
described the lag period from when
whenever you test positive to whenever
there might be hospitalization needed
so the peak is expected in the second
week of november
and it it's going to be slightly larger
than the initial modeling but the the
hospitals are now flexing their plans
to um to ensure that there are enough
beds converted to
manage covert positive patients and icu
as well
there may be a need to look at triggers
of when
elective care activity may step down
again but only for a short period of
time
but again they're managing that at a gm
level
and so that we're not causing health
inequalities
so it's busy there is a need to do
things differently
um but they have clear plans and a clear
understanding about how they're going to
manage
okay um is there any other
questions um we we are getting on a bit
in
time so uh if it did no other questions
um can i just ask
um heather fairfield
from healthwatch if you want to say a
few words
and i'll come back to martin
and neon yeah
um thank you chair um
as you probably know we have already
published an interim report
on uh findings around uh covert
um and literally while i've been on this
call the
the draft of the final report has come
through to me
there are perhaps one or two things that
will be of interest
to the committee and the first one which
was a little bit of a surprise in one
way but
not in another was that last year we had
45 000
hits on our website during the whole
year
in six months this year we've had 75
000 air hits so not quite double but
very very
significantly more and i think what this
does is it backs up the
um the need for the public to have
a very clear uh communication
uh really um there was a
an issue about that the largest reason
reason not to access
services was the feeling that this
wasn't necessary
and i think that that perhaps uh links
into some of the
uh the comments that were made earlier
but clear communication was felt to be
the most important way
that information could be improved
in terms of the feedback on the
um the website will be we've had
uh most people uh wanted to know about
a test and trace and the new 119
number uh whether people could get a
free
nhs test today uh
to check if you have coronavirus and i
think we've seen that
on the tv as well and then general
information
and news stories um that were asked for
in terms of youth watch trafford this
was
uh quite interesting um the warranty
young people wanted to know what age you
could visit their gp
alone um they wanted to know about the
mental health
hubs and again i think that reflects
back on what's been said
um they wanted information on young
parenting
as well um and they also wanted
information on going back
to school and what they should do
so we've come up with about um
seven main findings and we've come up
with a
an equal number really of
recommendations
um and i hope that you'll have the full
report with you
um in a short space of time uh
the other information that was sent
through to you were some of the
um the free text comments uh that we'd
had
and some were surprising uh some were
quite predictable really and some were
quite worrying but i think that people
generally are under a great deal
of stress and i think sometimes people
find that
um hard to articulate
as well um so i hope the report will be
uh of value um and thanks for the
opportunity to
talk to you about it i mean that that's
that's great i mean i i haven't seen the
the draft report um so so
it is something that i
believe that the committee would want to
um
you know have a look at and uh analyze
and
it'd be helpful obviously for you to put
your perspective on it all i think
you've given us a flavor
of it tonight but uh
yeah that that would be really useful
can i just say
to to naomi and martin
can i thank you for coming tonight and
um for for all the work
that you and all the staff you both
are doing and all the staff are doing um
and have done throughout this pandemic
it's absolutely
you know brilliant work and uh you know
i think uh
you know everybody in the country you
know is hailing the
nhs and all the workers and
uh we're no different doing a fantastic
job and uh and
heather you are as well you know doing a
brilliant job within the community
there's people like you that keep keeps
it all going
and i think um you know we
we we can't thank you enough really for
all the work that
you do um yeah so
so um i think they're all the
uh the items um on the agenda
in terms of um you know what questions
that we wanted
to ask and and so on um and
so so i'm going to close that part but
i'll keep holding the the members
because we just want to do a little bit
of a round up
um on issues so
um can i thank all all the people who
come along
tonight the the members and the officers
and
you know the ccg it's much
appreciated in public health and i think
the one thing that
has come over to me through all of it
and i know it has been mentioned
before you know the partnership working
is absolutely brilliant
and you know it to me it feels as though
it's seamless
and i think everybody's working together
you know tirelessly but
also excellently so thank you very much
for it
for all that you do for all the members
and
and officers so
so you can toddle off now um go go
um in the kitchen or downstairs or
wherever you're traveling to
today but thanks again
cheers can the other members just remain
because we've got a couple of bags thank
you chair
okay thanks
right um
yeah we we've just got uh another item
to
to deal with and that's uh items for
future meetings
um so i think um
we we do have a an agenda setting panel
which four of us sit on myself and
denise weston and
john and karen karen
and they we we usually meet um
the next day uh so that would be
tomorrow i i don't
is that still on alex i don't i don't
know whether
we're doing it is alex around
you know oh john john yes i'm still here
sorry
um i've not set one up for tomorrow as
it is uh friday tomorrow
um but yeah i'll set one up for the your
nearest availability all right so so if
we can meet
maybe i don't i don't know whether uh
john
and denise and karen uh
we'll be listening in is it the
executive on monday
we could tag it on to that yes the
executive on monday
so so we could tag it on to that
couldn't we six o'clock
yeah yes i'd be happy with that yeah
okay so so we can do that um
yeah because we'll need we we've got the
um i think the next meeting did in
november the 20 something um
so so we'll need to have some items in
relation to that
i think what one of the obviously what
heather said in terms of
the the report that she's um
you know she's developed and is in draft
form
if that's ready that would be quite a
useful uh
item to to to look at if we could get
that
early and we could uh analyze what
you know so some of the people in
trafford are
doing in terms of their health and
well-being
and what they're actually saying so
i think that that would be helpful um
yeah right i think maybe an update on
the school situation by then as well
given that um
you know they're increasingly being
impacted particularly as the level of
community infections
are increasingly i think i don't know if
you've already discussed it when you
were looking at it earlier but
um we didn't really do that we we
were looking at the offset so we didn't
really touch on that
maybe school attendance and things like
that you know how schools are keeping
going
that will be really starting to bite i
think by
november yeah
um is there anything that anybody wants
to say
i mean obviously we'll we you know the
the agenda panel will um
you know look at the items but
i think it's been a long long time
doesn't it we we're a bit over time but
we did start 10 minutes late so
um and you can you can feed into it
anyway you know
members can feed into us
and then we'll set an agenda for the
next meeting
i think um
as far as i know the the scrutiny
for budget um there are two meetings
uh two meetings date set aside the first
and the third
they they still stand under the alex
uh yes still going ahead with the first
and the third of december
yeah so so you know there will be
you know quite well will be three
meetings in close
succession really so
i would just need to bear in mind that
um when we set the agenda for the next
time
okay well i think you're you're all
tired out now so
so um i think
i know i've got on the agenda the
exclusion resolution but we don't need
that
um and i think the uh all the agendas
have been
dealt with so um
can i thank you all for your attendance
and
all of the questions uh
and have a nice evening this evening
thank you chairman yeah bye
[Music]
bye